[Music]
hello loyal viewers for those who are
just joining us that's me Megamind
master of all villain until I realized
my destiny was to be a superhero mega
mind is back I'm kind of a big deal and
you're welcome you're all so lucky to
have me as your hero wow you were
threatening the city a few days ago now
you're defending it I want to be a crime
fighter just like you you're adorable in
a pushy sort of way here's a souvenir
it's either a paper weight or a flash
grenade so careful with that from
Dreamworks Animation the Doom Syndicate
I despise them more than button- down
callers okay Mega Min that any way to
welcome your old crew you still think
I'm a villain let's have a good
oldfashioned crime spree or let's have
some fun before jumping into evil
business shrads anyone no act like a
villain until until I can stop them we
must keep up evil appearances sounds
pretty devious think like a hero those
bystanders are about to get squished it
does not look good for them oh right I'm
a hero now time to kick some Doom
Syndicate
booty oh guess it was a flash grenade
Mega mine versus the do Syndicate the
new film and if you love mega mind as
much as he does me is one of my favorite
things in the whole wide world
keep the fun going with mega mind rules
the new
[Music]
series